I remember reading the first few chapters of my hero academia back in 2014
Naruto was coming to a close and the torch was about to be passed down to the next great shounen series
It's funny how both
Naruto and my hero academia have the inherited will of the next generation as a major theme
I think in reality
My hero academia has inherited a lot that the previous generation has developed and made it its own
in the same way deku
Inherited his powers from all might and is now making them his own too
I don't know whether this similarity is by accident or whether the author horikoshi is
Inspired by his own situation and is making a focal point of his series
Well
Hopefully some of these awesome moments
Are going to inspire you to get into the series or, if you've already watched the show,
It will remind you of why you like it so much
Starting off at number 10 is the entrance exam's final moment
At the start of the show our main character, Midoriya, was pretty much a loser.
In a world full of special abilities, he was a quirkless nobody
and to make matter worse: He wanted to be a superhero
It's like wanting to be a pro basketball player, but not having any arms
He's recognized for his courage by all might who, luckily for him, has the gift of being able to transfer his ability to another person
It's all about the hero's journey here: a lot of shounen shows start this way
But then they get that one moment to shine and this was Midoriya's first "oh yeah, this is gonna be amazing" moment
At number nine we have All might versus Midoriya and Bakugou
Some lessons are learnt the hard way. The really hard way.
Hit over the head hard, slammed in the ground hard, stepped on hard... The inspirational quote goes "Nothing in life hits as hard as life"
Well, I'm pretty sure All Might hits harder
I think this is one of those moments that made Bakugou one of the most popular characters in the show
His "I'm not gonna back down" attitude and "no matter what the difference in strength is, I'll destroy whoever I'm facing" mentality
Makes you love him, even though he's a massive prick.
A massively lovable prick
Moving on to number eight we have Bakugou's rescue
This was a close one. A lot of us thought that we were gonna lose Bakugou here as well
Luckily for us, though
He's a badass that spits at the arm the Villains league extends to him
This arc starts off tense with the third villains League attack now bolstered by the new recruits
They kidnap Bakugou and try to recruit him
He gives them a "hell no" and then it all accumulates through an epic rescue orchestrated by Midoriya
The type that I would have perhaps wanted to see in another show 15 years ago
At number seven it's Stain's rage moment
Although All for one is stronger for most of us, Stains's the best villain of the show so far
I think we all just love people who don't back down when facing challenges larger than themselves
And characters that have strong consistent values. The hero killer's just like that.
Sure, his goal was to murder a bunch of pro heroes, too
But he's doing it out of his own twisted desire to purge society of all the fake heroes.
And it's still admirable how when faced against so many heroes
He doesn't back down
He even saves midoriya from a villain because he thinks he's someone who deserves to be a hero
When Endeavor, the second strongest hero, shows up does Stain run away?
No
He calls him a fake and starts walking towards him. That's the kind of attitude we all need to have just without the killing part
Next on the list at number six is when Todoroki uses his left
Two things make this moment amazing for me. The first is Todoroki's personal growth
My hero academia has a diverse and well-made supporting cast and Todoroki is one of my personal favorites.
He's someone with the most natural talent out of all of the next generation students and yet he suppressed his half of it
Because of his relationship with his father
This is the moment where he gets over his inherited past and looks towards his own self-made future
The second is the mentality of Midoriya
He encourages Todoroki to use his full power to get over his mental issues and grow as a person
And this opposes his personal goal of the moment to win the match
But it serves the greater goal of having a peaceful world by helping the allies grow as heroes
At number five it's All for one's introduction.
I'm really glad that in anime the villains are rarely overlooked
They play a crucial role in every series
and that's something I've covered in the top ten antagonists groups in anime
A hero's only as strong as the villains he faces with the exception of One punch man, of course.
The brighter the light, the darker the shade.
All for one is the darkness to All Might's light.
As much as All Might is loved, All for one is feared.
His presence, powers and dark philosophy all accumulate
into one of the best and most chilling antagonist introductions I've seen in shounen anime
Next on the list at number four is when Midoriya defeats Muscular
While there doesn't seem to be any official power ranking in my hero academia
Muscular was probably the most powerful opponent Midoriya faced up to this point in the show
Midoriya was once again pushed far beyond his limits when trying to protect someone
This characteristic of his was the reason why all might picked him as his successor
We saw that he made the right choice when deku managed to put everything in his attack to defeat muscular against all odds
It also shows why stain saved midoriya and thought he's worthy of being a hero
Midoriya has consistently placed his own life in danger to save others from danger
and in these moments is where he's always managed to shine the most
At number three, we have all might versus Noumu
The first attack of the league of villains was the first time we saw some organization on the villains part
The attack gave a lot of the students a chance to shine
Midoriya especially, but no one got as much of the spotlight in the attack as All Might
All might is a godlike figure that no one's been able to push at that point in the series (except for his own health)
Noumu, the artificial human made by one for all with the explicit purpose of defeating all might,
has the ability of shock absorption meant to counter All Might's strength.
This epic fight gave us the first full extent of All Might's powers:
both his physical strength and his mental fortitude
to overcome his own boundaries and push himself past his illness and limits
In second place it's the second fight between Midoriya and Bakugou
Unlike others who grew up with their quirks, refining them and making them stronger as they grow
One for all's already a full-grown quirk that's given to someone who has no idea how to use it
It's like giving a machine gun to a toddler
But then the person who received the one-for-all grows much faster than anyone
So from Bakugou's perspective
It must be infuriating to see the weak boy he''s known since childhood has now caught up or might even overtake him.
It's a lesson about not comparing yourself to others.
While both of these boys have grown up in strength substantially
Bakugou is not looking at his own growth, but looking at Deku's
Instead of finding joy in his own growth he finds pain in the growth of his classmate
I wonder if endeavor had this moment with All Might
And finally at number one it's the United States of smash.
All for one is the villain above all other villains
While in the show we're seeing a peaceful world where villains have retreated in a recent past
It wasn't always like this
At the start of the quirk era, crime used to rule society
At the top of this world ruled by villains stands all-4-one: the king of villains.
The turning point of the world was probably when All  Might defeated All for One
He was the third One for All user (that we know of) to attempt this and the first to succeed.
What we see in the show is a reenactment of their last fight years ago
That was probably the last time we got to see All Might at his full strength
And it was glorious.
Well, thanks for watching and this time we are having a giveaway so leave a like and subscribe if you haven't already
And you might be the lucky person chosen to inherit All Might's quirk.
I'll see you next time on Vinny tube.